[Music]  is that a new bra no we just made out a  couple times we just made out times  steve whistie you're an idiot student  more a beautiful way to another why was  your chest stone again  give me the Nanami I had a good time  [Music]  yeah that's depressing  Hey  I'm sorry about everything  people don't really say what they're  really thinking but you captured the  right moment I says what I might not  find anything and I found something  [Music]  either have you ever cared about her you  never even liked her  [Music]  Nancy wheeler just another suburban girl  who thinks she's rebelling screw that I  am NOT trying to be someone else well  get out what what is going on  [Music]  crazy the squirt isn't crazy  [Music]